- There is something serious
about this podcast I did the other day.
If you've not sat down
and seriously looked
at my content in a
little while or if you're
somebody super deep into my content,
an incredible job here in this podcast.
Going in a little different direction
about me and my mindset.
I have a funny feeling
when I read the comments
that this will be really talked
about and really analyzed.
I hope you enjoy it, I'm
very excited about it.
Sit down, grab a cup of eggnog and enjoy.
(upbeat music)
- [Female] A lot of people
try to get attention through
social media and making a business of it.
So what can be better than
to talk to an expert on the subject.
Welcome to this podcast, Gary Vaynerchuk.
How are you?
- I'm amazing, how are you?
- [Female] I'm fine, thank you.
- Good, thanks for having me.
- [Female] Listen, how
does one become an expert
on the thing that is
still growing and people
still try to figure it out?
I mean, social media.
- By being a practitioner,
you know, there was a day
when painting was new and
the people that became
good at it were the
ones that were painting.
It's amazing to me how many
people have opinions about
Facebook or Instagram of LinkedIn
or making videos or doing
this kind of podcast and
getting people to listen to it.
Whole lot of people with
opinions who've never done it.
And so I believe the great
way to be great way at
anything is to be a practitioner.
You know people ask me
all the time, I make the
analogy, you can read about
pushups, but if you want the
results that pushups give you,
you have to do the pushups.
And I just think a lot
of people with business,
entrepreneurship and
specifically being a social media
content creator or modern media
digital creator, read a lot,
talk a lot, pontificate
a lot and don't do a lot.
The way I figured out
how to have my podcast,
the way I figured out my
YouTube show, the way I
figured out everything I do is by doing.
And you're gonna get some bumps and you're
gonna make some mistakes.
I think most people don't
do because they're worried
about what other people think.
- [Female] And who are they?
What kind of generation
are we talking about?
- Everybody, you know I think everybody.
I don't think this is as
generational as people think,
I think this is more psychology
than it is, you know,
none of the four people
sitting in this room,
Babin's young, you're pretty
young, how old are you?
- [Sound Engineer] 35.
- Yeah.
- [Female] Gary's talking
to our sound engineer.
- That's right, I bring
everybody into these podcasts.
I like to break the walls
and visualize for you
everybody who's listening.
Look, the three of us, 35,
it's not about how old you are.
I'm 42 and I feel more curious
and more understanding of
the culture and the game than
plenty of people that are 18.
I think it's a mindset.
And so it's a very
interesting time to be alive.
There's so much opportunity and
I'm excited to be a part of it.
- [Female] But you are
a very, how do you say?
- Special.
- [Female] You're very special.
No but the thing is you have this
psychological skill that a
lot of people come to you
with a lot of problems and
they try to get advices
from you and you just give them advices.
What kind of skill is that?
- That's psychiatrist, that's
psychologist, that's right.
If I was the son of me instead of me,
I would've probably went
to a top five university,
and been a big time psychiatrist
or psychologist like, 100%.
Because I was born an
immigrant in a different
environment and probably
had a little bit too much
competitive, entrepreneurial DNA.
But yeah, I think it's
interesting as my life evolves,
that some of my natural
skills are becoming more clear
and it's less about being
a salesman or being good
at digital marketing.
I'm very comfortable giving
advice because I think I'm
undereducated and I
keep things very simple.
Like, human behavior
comes very natural to me.
Which is why I've been
very good at predicting
what people are gonna do next.
It's also the same skill
that allows me to know that
most of the people's issues
come from their parents
or the environment they were born in.
Most things are very simple.
We don't want to look them in the face.
You know, Facebook's not changing us,
Facebook's not making us bad people.
Facebook's exposing that
we were bad to begin with.
You know these are funny things to me.
They're historical, I'm
a big fan of history.
It was the one class I
was actually decent at
and I think that's another
thing that's worked well for me.
This is just rinse and repeat.
What's happening right now
on Facebook and Twitter
is the same reason that governments
when they want to be
dictatorships, control the media.
Because the media controls the mindset.
And so I think my skill is human behavior.
And I think my vice or my
intrigue on another part
of my life is building
business and I bought
Bitcoin in 2014, not because I guessed.
Not because of anything else, but because
I could see what was gonna
happen in '17 and '18.
Yeah I made the joke
earlier about special but I
do feel special and I
don't say that with ego,
I say that as a compliment
to my parents and to
my circumstance and to America and to
the Soviet Union, for that matter.
The circumstances of who I became
are far more the factor than me.
But I do see around corners,
and not because I'm Nostradamus,
but because I deeply am consumer-centric.
I watch what people wear.
When haircuts change,
I'm fascinated by that.
I would've been great in fashion.
If I had that gene.
Like my daughter's very creative,
and I can see she has a lot of me in her.
I can see her being a
big time fashion player
in the future because if
she deploys her creativity
to fashion and she can see around corners,
she'll be an innovator of style.
And so yeah things are very simple to me.
- [Female] But social
media and the human brain
goes hand in hand with psychology.
- The human brain goes hand
in hand with everything.
Social media's very important
because it's communication.
You and I, right now,
are sitting in some room,
at some conference,
this amazingly handsome,
talented, sound engineer
has a very small device,
doesn't look so complicated
to me, I wouldn't know
what to do with it, but it's not big.
I know that this whole enterprise here
is not costing a whole to create,
and not costing a whole lot to distribute
if you guys know what you're doing.
It doesn't cost me a lot to
distribute on my podcast,
which is a top 50 podcast in the world.
That whole enterprise used
to cost millions of dollars
in studio costs, in distribution cost.
We're living in the internet age.
- [Female] Why don't people
get this more and foster?
- Because people look backwards
instead of looking forward.
90% of people default
into looking behind them
instead of looking ahead of them.
It's the human psyche.
I think most people are scared of change
and they look for negatives.
There's people that are
trying to blame suicide rates
on social media, it's laughable.
The issue with suicide rates
in the world is bad parenting,
and many other variables,
and maybe social media.
But to binarily blame a
media is silly and so I think
there's a lot of
technology fear mongering.
One thing I like to say a
lot is that we put writing a
letter on a pedestal, but
kids that are texting are bad.
I think that's crazy.
The message is important, not
the thing that delivers it.
- [Female] You invested, as
you said before, you knew about
Facebook before Facebook was big,
and invested in Facebook,
Twitter, Tumblr, Uber,
and you are a rich son of a gun.
- Yeah.
- [Female] But how can
you inspire your kids.
I mean you had a total different.
- I can't inspire them in
the way that I was inspired.
- [Female] 'Cause they have too much?
- 100%.
And they have other things.
They have a father who's
gonna end up being famous.
And that might be good or bad.
First, the way I'm gonna
inspire my kids is to
first do what I always do
which is audit who they are,
not who I hope thy are.
I first have to deploy
self awareness and empathy
and understand who they are.
So for my daughter who's
eight, I'm starting to
get a understanding and in
three or four or five years
I think I'm gonna have a
very good understanding.
I'm gonna inspire my two
children and what I try to
inspire everybody who's listening to this
is I don't want them to become me,
I only what one thing
for people that I have.
Really, outside of health,
the only thing I wish
for people is them to love
what they do as much as I do.
When I do new podcasts or new
video shows, I love reading
the comments of the
audience that don't know me.
Inevitably, 5% of the audience will
leave a comment that refers to drugs.
If they want to be really
snarky, they'll say
cocaine, Ritalin,
they think that I'm on something
and I always reply, because
I've never tried smoking
a cigarette, let alone done Adderall.
So they'll say cocaine,
and I'll reply gratitude.
I'm so grateful that I do
what I love everyday, and what
I love for clarification, is
just being an entrepreneur,
playing, the challenges,
the risk, the excitement.
- [Female] But you're also
high on your own energy,
you have tremendous energy.
- I have tremendous energy
because it builds momentum.
When you're doing what you
want to be doing for a long
period of time, it builds momentum.
I didn't have this same energy
in school, I hated school.
I was optimistic, I was
high energy, that's my DNA,
but not like this, this is now a supernova
because now I'm 20 years
into being in my zone.
The breath of fresh air,
the exhale I had on the
first day that I worked
at my dad's liquor store,
like worked, like there was
no more school ever again,
that (exhaled) was incredible.
I will never replicate
that feeling again, I miss
that feeling, it's funny, I've
never talked about this out
loud, that might have been
the best day of my life in a
lot of ways, knowing that I
was embarking on the thing
that I was meant to do,
so if my children want to
give away all my money, want
to paint in the Himalayas,
want to start a shool, or
want to climb the mountain
and be bigger than me, I
just wanna inspire them to be
themselves and support them mentally.
- [Female] But shouldn't you,
that didn't like the school
system at all, shouldn't you
be the one to start a school?
- Mmm Hmm, I sure should.
- [Female] And?
- And I will.
- [Female] Call me.
- You got it.
And by the way, I think i
am, and I've always dreamed
of starting a school 'cause
I wanted to fucking stick
it back to them so that
we could build a school
for people like me.
What's interesting is I'm
realizing I'm doing it now.
I have an enormous amount of
10-15 year olds following me
across YouTube and Instagram,
and I'm teaching them, boy.
Maybe I'm not teaching
them the way that people
think teaching is done,
but I am teaching them.
And I see it.
Oh, I have a great story.
I was flying yesterday from
Gothenburg to Stockholm and I
sat with a man whose 18 year
old son is obsessed with me.
He lives in New Jersey, of
all places, small world.
And he said that I, so
he's telling me everything
and I'm very flattered.
And he's a young man,
this father, he's 44.
I'm 42, but he has an 18 year old son,
and he's saying I was a
good student, my son wasn't
as good, but he wants
to be an entrepreneur,
and he lives at home
still, and everyday I walk
to work, come home, anytime
I'm going by him when
he's out in his room and
working in the kitchen
or living room, I hear your voice.
And then he turned to
me, very emotionally,
and he said thank you,
and it's kinda making me
a little bit emotional right now.
He said, my son's such a
better man now because of you.
And then he started telling me reasons,
accountability, you know,
I'm teaching real stuff,
not memorizing who the
fourth president was.
And then he talked about
me talking about my father,
and he said his son's
very competitive with him,
and I was very competitive with my father.
But I put out some content
about how I think about my dad,
even though we're different,
even though there's a lot
we don't agree with, and he
said to me that his relationship
with his son has fundamentally
changed since then.
- [Female] What do you say
to these youngsters that
make such an impact to
those who are listening and
maybe haven't heard you yet.
- I tell them the truth.
I tell them the truth.
Their parents aren't
telling them the truth,
their school isn't telling them the truth.
I tell them the truth.
I tell them a lot of
things they like to hear,
like fuck the system, forget
about what your parents
want for you, this is your
life, do not live with regret.
And then I tell them other
truths they don't like
which is you're fuckin'
entitled, you haven't proven
shit, stop being full of
shit, like life is long,
be kind, nobody gives a
shit if you have a Mercedes
or a Rolex, shut the fuck up, get to work.
I tell them the truth.
- [Female] Okay, I'm laughing
here, Tom is as well,
because we have teenagers,
and you're right, anyway.
- And you know what, let's
hold onto that for a second
because this could be very
valuable for your listeners.
I'm fascinated by what you
just did to what I just said,
and how that plays out in my entire life.
When I go to Cannes for
the marketing festival,
and I go on stage and I
talk, and I talk about
stuff nobody agrees with,
me, in the industry.
But then at 2 o'clock in the morning,
they'll say to me after a couple
of cocktails, you're right.
When parents hear my
stuff, and they're smart,
they don't like a lot of
what I say, but they'll tell
me, you're right, you just did it.
What I'm trying to figure out,
is what makes one do
something that they know
isn't right, when they know what's right.
What is creating that behavior.
What I think is happening,
is they're worried about
what other people think.
I have a lot of empathy
for a 49 year old woman
raising two teenagers
in a neighborhood where
she has a lot of friends,
where she believes in
something, but she
doesn't do it because she
doesn't want the scrutiny
from the other moms.
I understand, I just don't know why she's
choosing herself over her children.
I think about that stuff.
I don't want my kids to be entrepreneurs.
Too many people think of
their children as property,
and as indicators of who they are.
And I understand that,
I get so proud when my
kids do things, I get it.
I just don't think it's in
the best interest of the kids.
And so I'm trying to
have conversations that
a lot of people aren't.
I just said that for the
last three minutes, because I
hope somebody on my vlog or
somebody on your podcast.
One, if one parent, one,
if one parent just got
inspired in the last
five minutes, those kids
lives are much better.
You know how incredible that is?
That's what media is, that's
the world we live in today.
I would've never been known.
- [Female] But the thing you
said, get your shit together.
- Yes.
- [Female] I recognize
that I'm the daughter of
immigrants as well, so we hear that a lot,
and I'm not saying that
immigrants are the best
people on earth, because we
create a lot of good teenagers,
but there is something
when you have to fight.
- 100%, five fold.
My kids can't be as hungry as me.
I think the challenge that you and I have,
as kids of immigrants, and
I'm an immigrant myself,
so I'm real close to it,
is I'm ideological about
the immigrant framework, I'm with you.
We know how lucky we are.
'Cause we're hungrier.
We know it's good, it's better.
Entitlement and prosperity
has flaws on the back end,
but I think the mistake a
lot of people make is they
try to fabricate the
reality of the situation.
I see a lot of my rich
friends send their kids
to Africa for two days and
think it's gonna change them.
I think what's better, is my
recommendation for anybody
who's listening who
thinks their kids are in a
situation that is spoiled
or entitled or fruitful,
my big thing is, I can't fake environment.
My kids live on the upper
east side of Manhattan,
go to private schools, have
friends who have private planes.
I myself, my daughter and
son went with me the other
day, I went to buy jeans
and buy them some candy,
I took eleven selfies.
I could choose to be rude
to people and say I'm
with my family, but that's not in me.
So I chose to do that, but
that's affecting my children.
My daughter's like, you're
famous, you're a legend.
And I can't fake their life,
but there is something I
think where you're going
that I think is super important.
I do think some things are non-negotiable.
So my kids are gonna be
rich, and they're gonna
be spoiled, they're not
gonna be as hungry as me.
When I was 12 I asked
my mom to buy Nintendo,
she said go buy it.
I figured it out.
I could do that to my
kids, but there's too much
surrounding the framework of our family
that that's now where I'm gonna go.
But where I am gonna go is the following.
So for example, something
that is very politically
incorrect, is to hit your children, right.
Not a big thing that we do anymore.
I'm very comfortable saying
on the record, I will hit
my child if they ever, ever
use my and my wife's wealth
to be rude to another child.
If my kids ever once, in
their life, make another
kid feel bad 'cause me and Lizzy are rich,
and they're using that to
make somebody else feel bad,
I will punch them in the face.
- [Female] I hope they
hear that, your kids.
- You know what's even better,
it's better than hearing it.
Whether they listen to
this podcast or the clip
and if they use it, if they
ever hear it, it's gonna
matter a lot less than
the fact that it is our
religion inside our home.
They've heard it, it's been heard.
They don't even know it
yet, but it's established.
And I think being kind is non-negotiable,
I don't need them to be as hungry as I am,
'cause they're not going to be.
I need them to be kind and I need them to
figure out who they are, and
then I need them to go all in.
If they make paintings out of asparagus,
and make $8 a year, I
will be very proud as long
as they have as much
fire in their eye the way
that I do about my thing.
My fire turned into wealth, I get it.
But there's a lot of people who have fire
who do much greater
things than create wealth.
I will tell you, I have
much more fire to inspire
people and make them win.
My personal wealth, once
I made $100,000 a year,
I thought I was rich.
That was big, I was pumped,
I'm still pumped, $100,000.
I can live very, right now.
- [Female] The first $100,000 is the best.
- Is big, I agree, and
so I don't like stuff.
Like I don't need money for anything.
So if my kids become
lecturers, but only make
$73,000 a year, they're
gonna make me very proud
as long as they're fired up and happy.
- [Female] Let's continue talk about young
people but also business-wise.
- Okay.
- [Female] There are a
lot of examples of brands
that are panicking,
believing that they are
facing their final days,
they buy consultants
to analyze the social
media, and they still fail
to reach out to millennials, for example.
And I think just to take an example,
I think only one of five millennials has
tried a Big Mac from McDonald's.
- Yeah.
- [Female] And I mean it
doesn't matter how much
social media they try
to expose themself in,
it doesn't work and so
then McDonald's started to,
why doesn't this work, what do you say?
- Well let's start with
this, if VaynerMedia
did the marketing for
McDonald's and they gave
me carte blanche, five
our of five millennials
would try the Big Mac.
I'm not joking.
I think I can get every fucking person in
America, including vegan moms,
to eat a fuckin' Big Mac.
I don't think McDonald's big problem is
the food trends, 'cause
they sell plenty of salads,
and they've got all sorts of reasons.
I think it's the marketing, I really do.
McDonald's spends 80% of
its money, 90% of its money
on traditional or traditional digital.
They're mailing in their
modern, contemporary,
culturally relevant
content in the seven places
that millennials play,
they're mailing it in.
- [Female] This is a
point, yes, but some other
economists say that
millennials don't buy it.
(static)
We're thought to think like
her, don't trust anyone.
- Meanwhile, millennials
are wearing Adidas,
and Vans and Champion hoodies.
Millennials buy plenty,
they're buying Smart Water.
Millennials are fucking people.
I can trick a millennial
to do anything I want.
- [Female] How should other trick them?
- By making things that
are valuable to them.
You know how I trick them?
By giving them what they want.
By not giving them what I want.
By being consumer-centric,
by listening to millennials.
Millennials will tell you what they want,
you're just not listening.
You know why?
Because older generations
have too much audacity.
I can get a millennial to
do anything I want because
I'm deploying humility and
I'm listening, that's why.
- [Female] Social media.
(static)
And you live in the US.
How can you use this fact of two cultures
business-wise, I mean
we are talking about.
- You know if I want to
be a big personal brand in
Moscow, I have more autonomy
to do that than I do
in New Delhi or in San Paolo,
so, one, I think anybody's
truth is very important.
One of the reasons I think
I do very well in urban
and hip hop worlds is
'cause I liked it as a kid,
'cause I spent a lot of time
with a lot of minorities.
'Cause 90% of the kids in
my college were a minority.
So I think that what's
amazing is if you're
willing to embrace your
truth, there's enormous
amount of strength in that.
So for example, there's
a lot of people listening
right now with diseases
that they will never
tell anybody, usually mental, right.
I'm very fascinated by
what's happening with
meditation, mental
illness, if you're bi-polar
12 years ago you're hiding it.
I think you need to expose it.
And so I think borders are not just
our ancestors and where
we're born, but it's what
makes us, I think there's
so much more that we
should be talking about
and taking control of it.
I, very early on talked
about being a bad student
when it wasn't that popular.
I cursed on content in
the early and mid-2000s
when that was not popular.
But it was my truth, I
curse, I'm a bad student.
And there's something very
powerful about truths.
So when I think about crossing borders,
if it's your truth you can
be unbelievably successful.
I also think just as very
tactical, I think it's
an incredible time to get
bigger in other places
if you're willing to
transcribe your content.
I'm transcribing my content
into different languages
and watching my popularity
grow in Italy and Asia
and in Spanish speaking countries.
It's very fascinating to see,
Facebook is such an incredible tool.
I think of the world as one world.
I do think Russia and I think
China have some different
variables because of their structure.
China's a big market
itself, it's got its own
insular culture, I think
Russia does the same.
But other than that I think
of the world as a one.
- [Female] And Facebook
helps us with that.
- 100%.
- [Female] How much time
does consumer spend time
with Facebook, do you
have a figure on that?
- No, I don't know what
the updated figure is,
but here's what I can
tell you, over 50% of time
spent on a mobile device
in the world is being
spent on a social network,
and Facebook has a
disproportionate amount of that time, so,
just ungodly hours and hours.
Today, as we record this,
if you add up the attention,
time, that is spent in
Facebook and Instagram
combined, it's extraordinary,
the power of that tool.
- [Female] How much
power does podcasts have?
- A lot, I think audio
is the next frontier
because it's passive consumption,
and time is very important.
So I'm very bullish on
podcasts, I'm very bullish
on Alexa and Google Home
and devices that interact
with you through voice.
I'm betting the farm on voice
being the next frontier.
- [Female] Wow.
Who's inspiring you?
- That's an interesting question.
I'm not sure.
So let me answer this honestly,
that's a good, you know,
I'm inspired by everybody and nobody,
if you wanna be honest.
I've never been framed up
as somebody who looked up
or admired people, outside of my parents,
and really even in silos,
my mom as a parenter and
as a human being, she gives
advice to everybody too.
Just in a much smaller circle than I did,
so I grew up watching that,
to your earlier question.
And my mom's very much my hero.
My dad from the work ethic,
you know the hustle thing
that I talk about, but it's interesting.
My wife, for her inability to complain.
There's a lot of people,
and then just silly
stuff, let's use Babin, he's in the room.
Watching Tyler work for me for a year,
knowing from day one he
came to work for a year,
use my name, and then go
out and do his own thing.
I knew it, I knew it.
And then to watch him
be able to recognize the
situation and realize it was
valuable for him to stay.
I'm inspired by that.
Now maybe that's me,
humble bragging and being
look how good I am, that's fine.
The millions of emails,
DMs and messages I get.
I mean listen, I get an
email and a DM on Instagram
everyday that is from
somebody that's homeless,
10 times a day, 20 times
a day from a single
mother in a really shitty situation,
30 times a day, 30 times
a day from somebody in
a mental negative state.
- [Female] Do you answer all?
- No, I wish, fuck man.
- [Female] But doesn't it
frustrate you to have so
many cries for help?
- No because I'm practical.
I am driven and inspired to be a good man
because I think people
are counting on me to be.
And I like the challenge.
I like the pressure.
It's what I'm comfortable with.
It's who I am,
- [Female] Gary, you should
listen to my podcast.
- Okay, I will.
- [Female] And I'll listen to yours.
Thank you for coming.
- Thanks for having me.
On this episode, this podcast I did,
what was the most interesting
insight you hadn't
heard before in this episode?
(upbeat music)